Secretary Robert Gates served as deputy
national security adviser and CIA
director under President George Herbert
Walker Bush he's worked under eight
presidents in his decades of public
service most recently a secretary of
defense under presidents George W Bush
and Barack Obama he's here for an
interview you'll see first on CBS this
morning mr. secretary good morning
thank you so of all those presidents
where does George Herbert Walker Bush
slot in well he clearly was my favorite
I spent the most time with him you know
during those tumultuous days in 1989
1990 91 with all the history that was
being made his national security adviser
Brent Scowcroft and I probably on
average spent two or three hours a day
with him and when he traveled
domestically I went with him I think it
was as much because he wanted somebody
to talk to about foreign policy or has
anything else we hear a lot about his
the attribute of a restraint with
President Bush how did that play out in
terms of national security specifically
with respect to the collapse of the
Soviet Union well I think I think the
best example and one where he was
criticized was he was criticized for not
celebrating sufficiently when the Berlin
Wall came down and what he understood
that very few of his critics understood
was that Gorbachev position in Moscow
was relatively parlous at that time and
the concern that he had was that if he
celebrated too much it could serve as a
provocation to the conservatives in the
Soviet Union who were still powerful in
the KGB the army and the party in fact
the same people who launched a coup
against Gorbachev two years later and I
think I think in retrospect he felt and
we all felt that had he pushed too hard
had he celebrated too hard that November
it might in fact have precipitated the
coup against Gorbachev a couple of years
earlier and and he may not have survived
it in fast forward to today when
Vladimir Putin calls the fall of
communism the worst devastation
it could have happened in the 20th
century let me ask you about something
that I keep hearing and reading from a
lot of Democrats too who have said they
voted for maybe one Republican for
president and that was George HW Bush
that in fact he may have been the best
president of their lifetime what do you
think it was about him that brought in
people from the other side of the aisle
I think it was his willingness to reach
across the aisle he he always put the
best interest of the country first the
decision that he made to compromise on
no new taxes was really putting I mean
he felt that was really necessary to put
the country on a sound fiscal basis
going forward and he was willing to work
with the Democrats to do it knowing full
well what the political cost would be
and so his willingness to put a partisan
agenda to make the partisan agenda
secondary to what was in the best
interest of the country I think had a
lot of appeal to the Democrats on the
hill I also think just it was his
personality the way he reached out to
them he'd have him down to the White
House for a drink in the evening he
cultivated him he spent time with him
he'd served up there so he knew their
practices he knew he knew the the way it
worked on the hill so I think it was all
those things that that made people
willing to work with him that said there
were still some pretty partisan battles
during that time and I remember him we
keep hearing about his sense of humor
his compassion you spent a lot of every
day you spent with him for at least two
years so you got to see him publicly and
privately can you give us an example of
his humor and an example of his
compassion he was he was just a lot of
fun to work for so my favorite he's the
only president I ever worked for who
actually created an award for the person
who most obviously fell asleep in a
meeting with the president the United
States
this wasn't frivolous yeah he evaluated
you in terms of the depth of your sleep
snoring always got your points that's
good the duration and then the quality
of the rakaat
did you did you just kind of return to
consciousness or with a joky oh that's
good
and it's his compassion I remember
vividly I flew down on the helicopter
with him to Norfolk after the tragedy on
the battleship Iowa in which a turret
blew up and killed 43 sailors and he
went down to the memorial service and on
the helicopter kept reading his remarks
and he kept breaking down and he said I
don't know if I can get through this I
said he said I once asked Ronald Reagan
how do you get through these things and
Reagan said well I just go over it over
and over and over in it and Bush said I
just keep going over and over and over
it and and I I just can't get past this
one passage so he he he gave the remarks
and you know as as is typical he got
criticized because he rushed through his
remarks and there were only a handful of
us that realized he rushed through his
remarks because he knew that was the
only way he would make it through
without breaking down and from a
national television audience he he felt
very deeply we talked about his sense of
humor that sense of humor sort of went
underground for the entire period of the
Gulf War
he knew the responsibility he was taking
on he knew that he was sending hundreds
of thousands of young Americans into
peril into harm's way and and a lot of
the joking around went away
frankly until after the war was over all
right mr. secretary thank you very much
for being with us absolutely